well you were the funny guy in prison
it's a bunch of funny people in prison
right what is that someone say that most
of the funny people are in prison what
is that what does that mean like the
funny guy in prison what does that mean
no i'm asking you you said you knew that
while you were in prison you knew you
were going to be a stand-up
humorous dude if people look at my stand
up now i'm not the funny dude now no i'm
i'm
the thoughtful humorous dude now but i
always ask because i don't know what
people mean by the funny
person in prison because
people
have a lie
or something from a movie embedded in
their head that never happened
so
i remember this i was on this on this um
radio show and this guy asked me so were
you the funny guy in prison so people
wouldn't mess with you and i immediately
looked at him like man who [ __ ] are you
talking to
like
like i and then i add i say if i was six
four
and i started in prison would you ask me
that question
because what make you think that being
funny in prison
would gain you some sort of protection
then i said because you [ __ ] thinking
about a movie some [ __ ] you heard on
house party that wasn't true
richard pryor
never went to prison
so no he wasn't in prison making jokes
so people wouldn't [ __ ] with him because
he never went to prison
that's a that's a movie [ __ ]
so i tell people i said so you thought i
was in the streets being some weak
[ __ ] before i and i had to get
funny in prison
to protect myself
i got security now and it's not for me
it's for the people
he'll tell anybody that
i'm with him so he won't [ __ ] y'all up
and that's the that's the honest to god
truth i'm like when people ask me [ __ ]
like man like
like right like
who you talking to
because if anybody know anything about
me
or even seen anything about me
i'm one of the most dangerous [ __ ]
people walking around
just
because i don't i've never started a
fight i've never started any altercation
but i finished a lot of them because
people say some disrespectful [ __ ] to me
i'm like man who [ __ ] you talking to
mm-hmm
what motivates motivation it's the same
it's the same mentality that i had in
prison
who
it's like if we was if we was in prison
you asked that question
it'd be prisons to be like yo yo yo yo
yeah yeah yeah
this not the one
for that right
when i did that when i did bigger than
these bars in prison
it was people who
it's an officer named woods that you'll
see him in the in the side corner
he knows the story it was the guy that
challenged me in there
and i said while you were in there
performing you're saying i said where
you want to go
what sale you want to go to
and i'm going to take my suit jacket off
and only one of us are going to come out
this sale so all that slick [ __ ] you
talking let's make it happen and then
all of a sudden
i mean i'm just [ __ ] around with you
but i'm not [ __ ] around though
so
you think i'm not you think
you slept that slick [ __ ] and it's like
it's over
oh man i'm just man you you you in here
performing don't try to give me no
goddamn i'm in here performing because
you said to stick [ __ ] first
so let me let me address let me address
it i'm an i'm a cat that went into
prison at 19. i was
135 pounds and i was 5 17. i'm 157
pounds now and i'm still 5'7 and
when people address me a certain way i'm
like
you do know like i still
get down like i
so
me being humorously sarcastic
while i was in prison had nothing to do
with protection
nothing
so when the people ask me was you the
funny dude i'm like that's that's why i
always ask what that means right because
i want people to understand whatever you
think or whatever that means in your
head
it's too many people it's too many
people that give that give a disclaimer
like hey what can i ask you a question
why um and i appreciate you like
full-on breaking it down how it works
that way i feel like
everyone has something that they rely
upon like you're a funny guy you're a
comedian i was a comedian for many years
i did it because
i had some serious
issues at my home going on right and i
used it to kind of deflect from family
issues so if someone asked me oh so
you're the funny guy in class well you
know yeah man actually i am
and i did it because i was dealing with
some serious [ __ ] that was going on
back at home so i almost think it's kind
of natural why someone would say well
you know why were you the funny guy why
were you you know so it's it's it's a
question that might that probably comes
up from time to time but your response
is like you don't know who i am no and
you also don't know you also don't know
uh prison right so it's like
it's you say were you the funny guy in
prison i feel like it's like it's
treating prison as if it was a high
schooler and it's like a yearbook thing
like i think it's just a lot more
serious and that's i think something a
lot of people need to understand because
i find and i have a you know i've met a
couple of people that have come out of
prison and dealing with like
the that world it's important to
understand that number one
when
like that life that that he has in there
or that they had in there that pass that
they had in there is a very serious time
you know so
people ask about it very candidly i bet
too right they go they go yo so what do
you do for fun in there you know we're
like yo what's the you know what i mean
like i've been this is the reason why
because people take this place
because of the orange's new black and
all right these desensitized shows they
take this place
and because of that house part that
house party
thing
gives gives a bad taste to anybody who
wants to come out of that place
and be different
what do you mean what's the house party
thing you're talking about that's the
that's the rich that's what people got
that
being funny can protect you thing for
gotcha got it that was it richard pryor
movie you're saying no it's a movie it's
the house party movie but the
inside when kid
couldn't play a movie from the 80s got
it right there with you
so when he when kid is in jail
and this old man says
man what he says what i'm going to do he
said with richard bryan he said when
he's in jail you remember the saying he
said when he was in jail he used to be
funny to keep the inmates thinking about
it
and that permeates in people's head
more than anything else because that
they've seen that scene
so
how people think about prison
and anybody who does something they
never asked
the person who came out of prison that
became a lawyer were you were you in
there helping people with cases
so they wouldn't you know got it
got it it makes sense it makes sense was
you in there tattooing but they wouldn't
like like that's the that's the and i
think on a bigger thing something that's
really dope that i want you to talk a
little bit more about is like yo orange
is a new black prison break that that
movie like uh even even movies like the
longest yard you know what i mean like
all of this all of that
it's it's a [ __ ]
it's
it's not
we're like oz like people used to think
odds was real i'd be like man you do
know none of this [ __ ] happens man
i said when you see a real prison show
let me tell you what a real prison show
is gonna show you yeah they're gonna
always do account time
they're gonna do a count because
why wouldn't you
it's the it's
it's the number one thing that happens
in prison what's a count time what is
that they count the inmates
got it because that's how they get paid
every day you're saying yeah you don't
know
six seven eight times a day
like you get counted
every shift twice
so you got three you're saying if you if
it counts if you're saying if you were
building a show that would be a major
part of it yeah it it has to because
it's
it's like
it's like showing prison with no bars
they're the bars are there the counter
got it so the count time has to happen
what are the other key elements if you
were building out a show not even yeah
count time that count time is huge but
also the things that people don't
realize what else like day-to-day [ __ ]
because i think it's so funny how like
they have no clue like you got counted
six times a day yes you get you you have
to give your you have to get your spin
number
every like you never hear anybody giving
a spin number on a prisoner like
if you hear inmates seven five four
three three they're not gonna call out
the number they're gonna say your name
you gotta say your number uh
you have to say your number it's like
when i hear people talk about oh i was
in prison a long time and i'm like oh
what's your spin number what's your
what's your main number oh man i don't
remember it [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's tattooed in your memory
great got it i know that number better
not know my social security number
really this is a number that i've tried
to forget
i've tried to forget this number and i
remember one time i thought i did
i was so goddamn happy
i
thought i was like i was like
i forgot the number
and then i was like [ __ ]
[Music]
you